think Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
particularly significant now to the
future of the royal family oh has that
exactly died down as it's gone on people
are losing interest I think you look at
the sales of Harry's book shows her
something or losing interest but I think
the narrative was settled I think public
view has settled it was interesting that
with the Netflix series and the various
interviews that went with that then we
had Harry's book and all the interviews
there was a fairly prolonged period of
noise of the solaharian Megan agenda but
the opinion polls didn't really shift it
didn't tell us anything we didn't know
already it's worth remembering that they
were a royal couple for six or seven
hundred days they've been a post-rawal
couple for twice that period now there's
only so much they can say about raw Life
as a couple because I think we've
probably heard it the one thing I I it
was interesting reading Harry's book
spare there was there was quite a lot
left out which makes you think either
there's possibly a sequel or perhaps um
Megan's got a book up her sleeves so
maybe that's coming down the track